quand père et moi mon flanc vous n'êtes
pas du tout a dit imitateur n'ont parlé
de thierry le luron
je sais que vous imitez de trois
personnes deux coups puis on pouvait
nous faire de trois gars ici même je
sais pas moi j'ai rien j'aime bien parce
que lui il est dont il est dans la
parodie en fait tiré une série il faut
que je me lève tard de l'énergie aie
table et il nous l'avait fait la
deuxième place et il l'a déjà fait
l'adiaf et michel roth que ça va mais
j'adore ça lui va
alors l ai dit je vais c'est de trouver
ans mais moi je trouve que cette
émission elle est complètement à jack
berdeil
alors n'est pas du tout ma femme on ben
laden à l'origine de moi ça a vraiment
un programme que je vois ça m'emmerde
série qu'est ce que tu en penses
j'adore je suis limité n'aura aussi non
ah cool cette équipe l'équipe encore de
l'équipe électif
j'avais de combat le fayot ça ouais je
sais juste faire est-ce que vous lui
aurez leurs illustrations de
mademoiselle juste c'est juste
quant au chalet que je vous adore quand
est ce que est ce que vous voudriez
prévenir dans l'équipe de touche pas vos
posts voir des trucs à faire je vois si
j'ai le temps mais j'aimerais beaucoup
vous attendez c'est pas vous avez envie
génial wi fi sont plutôt bien à la fois
que je viens je suis très en réussite
si c'est une invitation je signe aux
bottes ce n'est pas une invitation c'est
une proposition
et bien c'est une proposition acceptée